uh Lebron James tweets that black people
are afraid to leave their homes when in
fact it is rare for a white person to
kill a black person anytime it is rare
there about 20,000 homicides every year
most homicide is same race homicide most
blacks who are murdered or murdered by
other blacks most whites who were
murdered or murdered by other other
whites however every year there're
roughly 750 interracial black white
homicides 500 white people killed by
blacks even though blacks are just 13%
of the population 250 whites killed by
blacks even though black 250 blacks
killed by whites even though whites are
60% of the population it is very very
rare for it to happen that that's
homicide let's talk about violent crime
between blacks and whites roughly
600,000 such instances every year by
that I'm talking about attempted murder
manslaughter rape assault with a with a
weapon aggravated assault 600,000 every
single year 85 to 90% is a black per
white victim only 10% the other way
around so if anybody has a has a has a
grievance it ought to be white
people because the cuz the numbers
overwhelmingly show that they are more
likely to be to be victims of crime by
black people but here's here's the real
grievance it is white people who hate
white people so why guilty or well out
it's we would describe it as outgroup
preference this is the the the survey
that went viral several years ago white
Liberals are the only demographic with a
with a racial outgroup preference so uh
uh it's it so black people have a slight
bias towards black people Latinos
towards Latinos Asians towards Asians
white conservatives towards white people
liberals against white people so I don't
I don't think the issue actually is that
uh they have a grievance about
whiteonblack crime I think that white
liberals generally just don't like white
people and so if anything interrupts
their narrative about white people
that's when they go on the offensive so
for example Asians don't fit the The
Narrative of white privilege so Asians
don't get included in their in their
benefits package of how we got to help
minorities right so it's really just
white people are bad have a nice well I
I phrased it somewhat differently I I
said whoever said compound interest is
the greatest force in the universe and
by the way I checked it wasn't Einstein
who said it whoever said compound
interest is the greatest force in the
universe never encountered white guilt I
just think there's a whole bunch of
white people that feel really really bad
about slavery really really bad about
Jim Crow really really bad about how
black people used to be treated and this
is their way of making up I I I I hear
you and I can understand that but I kind
of think they're just white supremacists
and I mean that in the literal sense we
saw that Yale study we love to cite
where white liberals
speak down to black people and white
conservatives don't white conservatives
meet a black guy they talk to them like
normal white liberals they they dumb
what up they but but not even that they
they like they use second grade
vocabulary like the these people in my
mind I don't think they have white guilt
I think they have a white superiority
complex where they imagine them going
like well we're so much better than they
are they need our help that's but I'll
give you a quick example it's White
Man's Burden
right that so I met uh uh these
activists when I was in North Dakota at
the no Dakota access pipeline protest
and I'm there to document stuff but of
course it's all leftist protesters who
are very you know woke and I'm sitting
down for dinner because I I friends of
friends and we get into a conversation
this one guy brings up you uh so what
happens is I said I got to leave
tomorrow because I have I have to drive
to California I have a meeting in the
more at 00 in the morning in 3 days so I
got to drive overnight and he said and
he smirks and
says a meeting at 9:00 a.m. he's like
that's Colonial thinking and I asked him
what is colonial thinking what I have a
meaning and he's like it's Colonial
thinking dude like having a schedule to
wake up you think the Native Americans
do that they wake up when they need to
wake up they wake up when the sun comes
up and I was like n white people didn't
invent time or scheduling dude and he
was like yeah they did it was the
colonists who brought all that stuff and
I was like bro people in Asia have time
and can track the hours of the day and
decide we should meet at a certain point
of the day and he goes no it's it was
white people who brought that and I was
like my dude the Chinese invented
compasses 1,000 years before you did and
he goes no it's it's white Europeans who
brought all that stuff to China and I'm
like holy crap this guy literally thinks
white Europeans invented everything
developed science technology and then
exported that to Asia and I'm like is
this true China invented compasses a
thousand years before Europeans did I
don't hold that against or in I don't
say wow AIA you're so great or you're so
dumb it's just a thing that happened but
these people believe white people
invented everything they're just white
supremacist they invented it to oppress
other people that's the other part to
benefit themselves and to make it harder
for everyone else to exist they made the
compass to control Direction so that
yeah they invented racism they invented
gravity to keep us all down I mean like
what people are out of control that's a
joke but like when it comes to like
racis they could they have part of the
theory is white people created racism in
order to oppress other
races video that Amy Horwitz did
regarding voter ID oh it's a class oh my
they ask all these college students um
you know why is it that black people
can't get voter ID well they just they
don't don't have access to the internet
don't so he goes to go them uh he says
do you what he he asks them do you think
a black person would not be able to get
an ID or whatever and they'll say yeah
they said no yeah they couldn't they
they don't have access to the to
computers unre they can't find the DMV
so they go to they go to Harlem do you
have a ID yeah I got an ID you know what
you know you know anybody who has I
don't know anybody who doesn't have ID
my favorite my favorite I have to bring
up my favorite my favorite is they one
of the one of the excuses the Berkeley
kids give is they they have trouble
finding the DMV right and so he meets
this like older black guy and he's like
can I ask you a question he's like yeah
and he's like do you know the DMV is and
he goes oh yeah just go up here on 25th
he's giving him directions because a
normal question that's the thing it's
like it's like and one woman was was was
was told that a lot of people don't
think you can get
and she said who thinks that and he said
you think it's racist she said yeah kind
of there's there's this thing that goes
on in in like the the critical social
justice movement and stuff is they they
want to think about their Blackness
first and it's like they're forget that
they're people it's like these are
normal people things to do finding out
where in the city a building is is not
some massive challenge the idea that a a
whole entire race can't find an address
look look look it's so offensive I think
think about what these Berkeley kids
must think of the average intellect of a
black person who can't figure out what a
building is a few blocks away I mean
that is a it's a white supremacist idea
people could not find a building I'm on
the campaign I announced before Tim
Scott did Tim Scott announces I get a
phone call from a
reporter you and Tim Scott are both
black Republicans what distinguishes you
from Tim Scott I said I said in 2016
When Donald Trump announced it you say
you are both white Republicans what
distinguishes you from Jeb Bush and she
was quiet for 15 seconds she said Point
made but she's not sorry she asked she
said Point made but she's going to ask
it again she she was through the
question so I didn't I mean what from
Tim Scott I would have trolled her
relentlessly like I would have just
started I said I'm better looking no I
mean I would just started I would just
say a bunch of like self-deprecating
racist things like is is that what you
wanted to hear ridiculous no it's crazy
but I do think that they
ultimately race as as at the Forefront
of a progressive mind always and they
are always because they're all I think
whether it's they hate themselves
because they're they're it's whatever it
is they ultimately use that to say well
everything I've heard that is a
stereotype about another race that could
potentially be perceived negatively I
have to make sure I'm on guard against
it at all times which is way worse what
you're describing is the result of
people being taught critical race Theory
critical race theory in of itself is not
ideas critical race theory is a way to
approach the world it is seeing race
before anything else so when we were
arguing oh we don't want to teach kids
critical race Theory we weren't arguing
oh you don't want kids to know history
or know that there are different types
of people different color people in
America whatever it is we don't want
people to have the illiberal view that
race comes before the human being I got
to I got to read this Super Chat from uh
Jason Hutchinson cuz he makes a really
good point black people work at the
DMV but they get lost all the time dude
these these these these Berkeley College
kids are like that that racist if you're
black and you get hired at DMV
have I make this point in my book I was
in Boston in 2004 when this guy with
funny ears skinny guy whose name nobody
could pronounce came out and gave the
intro speech for John krey and Barack
Obama said there's no blue America
there's no red America people win nuts
there's no black American there's no
white American people went nuts he
decided to run for president he's on 60
Minutes he was not yet the front runner
but he's catching Hillary and the
correspondent said Senator if you don't
win will it be because of race and I sat
back and I said let's see what this guy
says he's going to give some sort of
victorr answer the way Al sharpen did
when he ran and lost and claim was
racism or Jesse Jackson ran twice and
lost and said it was racism Senator
Obama said no if I don't win it will be
because I have not articulated a view
that the American people can can Embrace
he also gave a speech a black church
when he was running he talked about how
much racism he thought was still in
America and he said the Moses generation
referring to the generation of Martin
Luther King the Moses generation has
gotten us 90% of the way there my
generation the Joshua generation has to
get us at additional 10% which I thought
Phil was reasonable because there was a
fox opinion poll 2002 8% of Americans
believe Elvis is still alive 6% believe
if you send him a letter he'll get it so
8% 8% you got to wipe out so basically
what he was saying we have 2% to work on
he gets elected both polls show that
blacks and whites thought race relations
would improved when he left both blacks
and whites thought they got worse why
for 8 years this dude played the race
car Time and Time and Time Again from
the police Cambridge Police acted
stupidly Trayvon Martin he invoked black
lives matter he talked about Ferguson at
at a UN speech gave an interview to a
podcaster and said racism is in
America's DNA so this this is What
communists do and then and then he
brought in Al sharpen over 70 times what
happened to the guy that I saw in Boston
yeah that's What communists do thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net